scp-682 vs scp-053  what happens when you pit the  hard-to-destroy reptile against a very  lonely very deadly little girl this  foundation cross test allowed us to find  out 053 has the power to turn people  into violent maniacs who then  immediately die when they try to attack  her researchers hope the same thing  would happen to scp-682  in fact the absolute opposite happened  053 seem to be one of the only creatures  in the universe that 682 becomes totally  docile around and despite 053's initial  fear of the beast she soon plucked up  the courage to approach and make a  friend the two played together with 682  even allowing 0-5-3 to draw on its face  both became distressed when the two  separated 053 began to cry and 682 went  berserk and started killing people sadly  for both of them the foundation has  deemed shared containment to be too much  of a risk to ever be allowed